hello and welcome to the new world
review a source for everything anime and
manga and today we have returned to the
realm of jujutsu kaisen at which point
we promptly find ourselves with one
megami fushiguru an extraordinarily
powerful and extraordinarily
spiky-headed 15 year old who is
legitimately one of the most intriguing
characters within the entire series and
when intrigued is peaked knowledge must
be seeked and yes i know that it should
be sought but that doesn't rhyme and i
have no time for that sort of crime so
instead i'm going to offer 10 fun facts
that you did not know about megami
fushiguru or maybe you did but you
probably didn't know all of them and
even if you did well it looked good for
you you got me there but the only way to
know for sure is to strap yourselves in
and activate the emergency subscribe
button for the new world review the
pressing of which will form a binding
vowel allowing consistent injections of
jude's culture administered straight
into your youtube feed but let's get
into the thing that we are going to get
into with fushigoro fun fact the first
which is that he is the first character
to be seen in this incarnation of
jujutsu kaisen now of course some
caveats here the jutsukai sin prequel
was the original story of this universe
and with that in mind yes you could say
that yuta is the first character
technically introduced but within the
sequel the first fancy face we see is
megami fushiguru looking particularly
annoyed puzzled and perplexed as is
often the case when he or anyone else is
conversing with gojo very notably this
was changed in the anime and the first
character to be seen are the legs of
yuji itadori which i imagine are named
ita and dory respectively then of course
we do also see the rest of yuji but that
that doesn't matter however in the manga
mr megami is the very first face to
grace us and i take the trouble to point
that out because i do believe this was
quite a deliberate decision there are
some fun parallels between megami and
the former jiu-jitsu kaisen protagonist
yuta okotsu that will become clear in
future fun facts but for now just take
solace in the fact that the very first
face that geiger akatomi wanted you to
see was this grumpy mofo and holding the
title of lord grump our second fun fact
is that fushiguru is extraordinarily
skeptical in the jujitsukai-sen fanbook
akatami stated that fushigura quite
keenly keeps up with all of the news
whether that be on tv or a newspaper or
any kind of like online news dispensary
however akitami also made mention that
while he ingests a critical amount of
current events fushigoro is highly
skeptical and tends not to believe half
of what he hears and i mean sure how
does the old saying go if you don't read
the news you're uninformed but if you do
read the news you're misinformed while
fushiguro does prefer the latter
although he applies a large degree of
critical thought in addition to this
akutami has also noted that fushigo is
quite overly negative and even
misanthropic the shigeru himself has
also stated his philosophy that the
world is simply designed to be unfair
and nothing we've been shown introducing
really contradicts that so it does seem
like a reasonable opinion the point
being that it takes a lot to gain his
trust which is why yuji is quite the
special boy not only did he break
fujiguru's pessimistic mindset but he
also very quickly earned his trust it's
very odd in retrospect but that is the
power of the shonen protagonist
meanwhile akutami put quite a bit of
thought themselves into the name megmi
fushiguru megami's name is actually
quite relevant within the series itself
and it has been brought up on multiple
occasions you know due to how feminine
it sounds and that's because megami
whilst not exclusively so is more often
than not a name given to female children
the kanji itself is one of the most
popular because it means all sorts of
you know wonderful things such as
blessing gift from heaven luck favor
intelligence etc it goes on and on and
on if it is a good thing megami probably
means it and you know what i'm just
gonna go ahead and say it this kanji is
opie and as such if you were a japanese
parent of any child then it would be
almost a crime not to assign them with
the megami kanji and as for fujiguru
this actually follows the gege akutami
protagonist naming scheme coming
directly from the fushigura plant in the
same way that yuji itatory takes his
name from the itadori plant sadly
however the kanji used to construct this
name pretty severely contrasts the whole
megami portion with fushi meaning to
drop or lower and guro simply meaning
black so i suppose the overall message
that we have with megumi fushiguru is
that he is a kind blessing lowered into
an extraordinarily dark situation which
definitely does seem pretty spot-on
considering his role in the series and
we can see this at work with fun factor
four which is that fushigura actually
becomes quite depressed when hishikigami
die as do i honestly because i was not
ready for the loss of divine dog model
white and i am legitimately terrified
every time fushigoro summons a shikigami
because every battle could be their last
but i'm also quite curious let me know
down in the comments below what your
favorite fushiguru shikigami is i'm
going to put in a preemptive vote for
max elephant because i do like the idea
of an elephant named max and this is
where fushigoro's kind-hearted niche
really shines through azakitami has also
identified him as the kind of person who
gets more upset when animals die than
when humans die which really highlights
the meaning of his name such a sweet boy
engulfed in horrific darkness
perpetually forced to use his animal
friends for combat it's sort of like
pokemon in a way just the more
high-stakes version and team rocket is a
cursed king who is trying to steal your
body because seriously nobody should
look at a 15 year old the way that
sukuna looks at fushiguru but maybe
sukuna is just curious because those who
have read both the manga and watch the
anime will note that fujikura's hair
differs quite greatly between the two in
the manga early fujiguru had quite
modestly spiky hair however the anime
turns his head into a full on hedgehog
and there's a couple of fascinating
reasons as for why this was done one of
which is that akutami is very conscious
that drawing fushiguru can often end up
looking like the frame of yuji so as
time went on akitami made fushigo's hair
longer and more hedgehog-like in order
to give him a stronger contrast to yuji
but this whole issue stems from
something even cooler than that because
when making the sequel jujutsukai-sen
series akutami had to create a new
protagonist being yuji but to keep him
distinct enough from yuta akutami gave
yuta's basic hairstyle to fushiguru
because i guess they really liked it and
didn't want to part with the style but
in addition to that yuji inherited
inumakiser so in a way the yuji and
fujiguru duo are just a flipped
perspective on the yuta and inumaki doer
and it's kind of crazy because now when
i look back at the chapters and i see
inumaki and yuta on the same page all i
see is yuji and fushiguru to bring
things back to something of a somber
note how six fun fact is not in fact fun
at all and that's because akitami has
confirmed that due to fujiguro's long
career as a judith sorcerer he has
actually had several friends die which
is interesting because in the series he
and kukisaki have a discussion about
death after that whole and that yuji
dying incident and fujigoro claims that
this is the first time that a classmate
of fierce has died being very specific
about the term classmate which i don't
know does that make our kitami's
statement even more depressing when i
first read that i thought it was
referring to friends who may have
studied alongside fushiguro and signed
up for that brutal brutal world of
jujutsu's stuff but apparently over the
course of his short life which gurus had
several friends who have just passed
away which is quite sad but i suppose
that's one of the many reasons why
fushigura had to mature very rapidly
into the lord of gloom that he is today
now the next fun fact took me a bit back
when i first heard it but despite being
roughly about the same age fushiguro is
actually the nephew of makizinen as well
as mai we shouldn't forget mai so maki
and mai are one year older than megami
but when it comes to the xenon family
tree maki's father is megami's grand
uncle with megami technically acting as
the youngest generation of the clan and
just to clear something up here before
the comments go crazy with all the
people that start sentences with the
word actually obviously in western
culture mai and maki would be fusikaro's
cousins however in most asian cultures
this would be considered an aunt nephew
relation and given that jutsu kaisen was
written by a japanese person in japan
and the story also takes place in japan
we're gonna go with that and it has more
to do with generations so maki and mai
would be the cousins of toji fujiguru
because they're from the same generation
however because megami is one generation
below them that activates a sort of
respect dynamic and so maki and mai are
treated with the role of ants so it's
always interesting how families work out
like that although i mean nothing will
ever be weirder than jojo's bizarre
adventure where jono giovanna is
technically joeling cujo's great great
grand uncle despite the fact that he is
only six years older than her there's no
time travel involved either that's just
how crazy jojo is for you before i go
too deeply down the jojo hall let's get
back to fushkura with fun fact number
eight which is all about his birthday so
while researching for this video i came
across a lot of fushiguro knowledge
dumps all of which mentioned his
birthday as something along the lines of
megami fushigo was born on december 22nd
and that makes him a capricorn which is
nice and all but for whatever reason
none of them seem to actually mention
the significance of the december 22nd
date this day falls smack bang in the
toji period for japan the winter
solstice essentially which occurs
between the 21st 23rd of december and of
course it is known for being the longest
night of the calendar year so that is
very significant because it further
emphasizes fushikura's relationship with
darkness if it wasn't bad enough that
his technique revolves around shadows
and the kanji for black is literally in
his name while he was also born on the
longest night of the year this man oh
boy i suppose cause he's not a man
whatever he is he is destined for
darkness furthermore toji also happens
to be the name of megami's father albeit
constructed with different kanji but the
intent is pretty clear it's a very
clever japanese pun and i love the
effort that akatami puts into small
details like this because think about it
megami was born ontoji from the peen of
toji for something a little less
profound fun fact number nine is all
about social interaction and in this
case specifically it has been noted by
akutami that fushigoro does not respect
his senpai inumaki by which i mean
fushiguru affords all of the superficial
respect that a child exactly one year
older than him deserves but the reason
why fushiguro has a secret bout of
disrespect is because inumaki gets
easily caught up in shenanigans quite
specifically the shenaniganory of panda
and gojo i suppose unamaki is a sort of
social chameleon who can adapt to
whoever is around him and sadly for
fushikura the concept of having not only
one but two gojos also known as gojai
for plural is quite a terrifying and
mildly annoying prospect but it is gojo
that leads us into fun fact number 10
which is that one day megami fujiguru
could very well be as powerful as satoru
gojo or potentially even greater
fushiguru is a great sleeping giant of
jujitsu kaisen someone who with each and
every arkhans up completely surpassing
every expectations i thought i had for
him and gojo himself has stated that
megami very much is the shining future
of this world and capable of at the very
least equaling him one day which is my
favorite fun fact of all because the
fushigoro hype train has well and truly
left the station at some points he even
feels more like the protagonist than
yuji does and in the end if fuji were to
die then i can see fushiguro being the
person who lingers and fulfills the gojo
role going forward in the next
generation and more on this topic here
is a bonus fact which is that gege
akutami has already decided how
fushigoro's story is going to end
whatever happens to this magnificent
hedgehog it is now set in stone which is
interesting because other characters
like yuji are admittedly still up in the
air and open for change so i'm not sure
whether to be happy or terrified that
fushigura has such a clear path forward
all i know is that i do trust gegekitami
to bring this character to a satisfying
conclusion no matter how happy or
depressing that may be for some enhanced
satisfaction however do go and check out
this video there is always more to learn
discover and enjoy about this series so
i look forward to seeing you there